[Música]
estamos enfrentando una crisis sanitaria
que nos plantea enormes retos y la
educación es posiblemente uno de los
ámbitos donde con mayor fuerza esto se
está expresando de forma inesperada los
estudiantes han tenido que dejar sus
aulas y el profesorado se ha visto
frente a una situación inimaginable
hasta hace solo unos pocos días en este
contexto como podemos desde la formación
docente ayudar al profesorado a estar
preparado para hacer frente a una
situación así priorizando sobre todo a
aquellos docentes que han estado más
expuestos a la brecha digital
bueno me gustaría comenzar diciendo que
cuando hablamos de preparar a las
personas docentes para hacer frente a
los desafíos actuales no nos estamos
imaginando una transformación masiva
hacia la formación virtual entre otras
cosas porque la interacción física entre
estudiantes y docentes va a seguir
siendo una pieza fundamental del proceso
educativo sobre todo mientras no
tengamos acceso garantizado a los
equitativo a los recursos tecnológicos y
al internet de alta calidad
lo que nos estamos imaginando son
docentes que son capaces de convertir a
las tecnologías digitales en sus aliadas
en los desafíos que de verdad son de
fondo y que están haciendo que la
profesión docente sea cada día más
complicada más compleja y que tienen que
ver con por ejemplo con desarrollar en
sus estudiantes habilidades de alto
valor cognitivo que son las que hoy en
día necesitamos o brindarles la
formación emocional social del carácter
que van a habilitarles para ser personas
felices y realizadas o atender la
creciente diversidad que tenemos en
nuestras aulas de necesidades y de
intereses
y esto que les estoy planteando no es
fácil para muchas personas docentes
supone un proceso largo y a menudo lleno
de obstáculos y quienes trabajamos en
iniciativas de introducción de
tecnologías digitales en educación
sabemos que esto es así y que a pesar de
que hay muchos docentes que han avanzado
ya en el proceso todavía queda mucho
camino por recorrer y así nos lo
confirma el informe pisa-- que nos
indica que el 50 por ciento del
profesorado a escala mundial todavía no
se siente cómodo en entornos de
enseñanza digital
sin embargo la crisis actual nos está
brindando una oportunidad grande verdad
de forma inesperada de forma
sorprendente y es que los docentes que
hasta ahora quizás los que menos
relación habían tenido con las
tecnologías digitales se están dando la
licencia de probar cosas nuevas de
experimentar de ser aprendices de nuevo
de salir de su zona de confort y de
mostrarse a sí mismos que si son capaces
de manejar recursos que hasta ahora
veían como algo extraño e inclusive
amenazante y esto es lo que le ha pasado
al profe rubén que ha querido compartir
con nosotros su experiencia en el
siguiente vídeo y que representa muy
bien a este grupo de docentes que se
está animando con entusiasmo a innovar
sus estrategias y aquí agradezco por
haber querido compartir con nosotros el
día de hoy su experiencia
hola mi nombre es lo bien por los campos
soy profesor de artes plásticas en la
regional de puntarenas en el liceo hecho
mes y deseo josé martín
en esta temporada que iniciamos con lo
que es la pandemia en costa rica como
docente enfrentado a los retos más
importantes de mi vida como es la
implementación de las herramientas
tecnológicas dentro del proceso
educativo hay enseñanza-aprendizaje para
mí ha sido un reto muy interesante
porque me ha hecho actualizarme cosas
que tal vez una vez se lo dejara de lado
me ha actualizado y estaba incorporando
para dentro de mis clases lo que la
utilización del classroom su tiempo
bueno y el más viejito de todos que era
whatsapp verdad entonces para nosotros
bueno para mí como docente la
implementación de estas herramientas ha
sido sumamente importante para poder
llevar el proceso educativo a la vez con
este trabajo autónomo
y aprovechando para lo que es
desarrollar en el estudiante el
pensamiento crítico el trabajo en equipo
tal vez aspectos que no se pueden dar
muchas veces dentro de la clase y ahora
se están evidenciando más entonces
volviendo a la pregunta inicial que nos
hacíamos cómo podemos desde la formación
docente apoyar a profes como rubén en
estos esfuerzos que están haciendo cual
consideramos que es la formación más
efectiva para ellos bueno pues la
experiencia lo que nos dice es que las
personas docentes valoran tres cosas en
la formación verdad tres que les quiero
compartir ahora en primer lugar que sea
pertinente relevante que ellos puedan
tener la oportunidad de escoger aquellas
temáticas que más se ajustan a sus
intereses y sus necesidades en segundo
lugar que sea flexible es decir que
puedan ir apropiándose de estos
conocimientos a su propio ritmo en el
orden que consideran más oportuno
encontrando bueno los espacios de tiempo
verdad que van sacando aquí y allá allá
donde se encuentran en sus casas de
camino al trabajo y en tercer lugar que
sea colaborativa es decir que les
permita encontrarse e intercambiar con
colegas con quienes comparten
preocupaciones intereses y crecer juntos
en este experian este intercambio de
experiencias profesionales bueno cómo
ven es algo bastante diferente del tipo
de formación al que veníamos estando
acostumbrados y que parece que todavía
incluso sigue vigente en algunos
contextos donde son otras personas las
que deciden en que tenemos que
capacitarnos en qué momento de qué forma
con qué secuencia
así que bueno pensando en garantizar
estas tres características fue que
nuestra primera gran apuesta fue lanzar
plataformas de cursos virtuales abiertos
a todo aquel que estuviera interesado en
llevarlos y es así como tenemos pues ya
varias plataformas de estas y algunas de
ellas especializadas en formación de
docentes como por ejemplo el campus
virtual
desde costa rica tu clase tu país desde
chile escolar tyc desde españa otras en
cambio son genéricas pero si tienen una
oferta de interés para docentes como por
ejemplo el xxi curso era por mencionar
sólo algunas de las más conocidas
pero déjenme llamar su atención sobre un
aspecto especialmente novedoso del tipo
de formación que estamos brindando en
esta temporada
y es que estamos implementando en nuevos
formatos y soluciones de formación
virtual pensados especialmente para
llegar a aquellos docentes que más lo
necesitan por ejemplo docentes que no
tienen una conexión permanente a
internet o aquellos que no han tenido
mucha experiencia y por tanto no tienen
mucha fluidez en el manejo de las
tecnologías digitales y para ello nos
estamos valiendo del hecho de que ya la
gran mayoría de docentes dispone de un
celular con una conexión al menos
intermitente a internet y que también
muchos de ellos están presentes en las
redes sociales
entonces apoyándonos en esto estamos
lanzando actividades como por ejemplo
transmisiones en vivo en redes sociales
donde ellos tienen la oportunidad de
establecer contacto personal con
asesores que les aportan consejos sobre
cómo dar sus primeros pasos en el uso de
las herramientas y que además también
están cumpliendo otra característica y
es que les transmiten seguridad porque
ellos se ven que son parte de un
colectivo más amplio de personas que
están pasando por la misma situación por
la misma experiencia precisamente en una
de estas
transmisiones es que tuvimos la
oportunidad de conocer al profe lubín
otra actividad también que estamos
ofreciendo son mini talleres virtuales
en pequeño grupo donde los docentes
pueden aprender y poner en práctica
habilidades muy concretas útiles
relacionadas con el manejo de los
recursos y cómo usarlos en el trabajo
con sus estudiantes y otro tipo también
de actividad a la que le estamos
invitando a participar son tutorías
virtuales muy fáciles de accesar a las
que ellos pueden llegar para plantear
aclarar dudas y plantear sus ideas y
recibir realimentación escuchar ideas de
los demás en fin cómo ven un conjunto
muy variado de opciones que representan
un verdadero menú de aprendizaje a la
carta que estamos ofreciendo a las
personas docentes y en las que estamos
en donde estamos aprendiendo juntos la
está de la mano de todos ellos
y para concluir quisiéramos compartir
que sentimos que tenemos buenas noticias
porque porque por un lado contamos con
un número creciente de personas docentes
que están abrazando esta oportunidad de
cambio y por otro lado contamos con un
menú de aprendizaje a la carta con una
oferta de formación que es relevante que
es flexible que es colaborativa y que
estamos enriqueciendo con nuevos
formatos de formación virtual que están
demostrando ser especialmente eficaces
para llegar a las personas docentes que
hasta ahora habían estado un poco más
ausentes de este entorno de enseñanza
virtual
en fin sabemos que el principal reto a
la hora del regreso a las aulas va a ser
acelerar el proceso educativo para que
los estudiantes especialmente aquellos
que han estado más desconectados en este
periodo puedan recuperarse y nivelarse
pero nos gustaría también no perder el
momento el impulso del momento y el
regreso sea unas aulas distintas donde
estudiantes y docentes sigan dándose la
oportunidad de experimentar y crecer
juntos muchas gracias
[Música]